Jaguars running back Travis etn and if
you just grown good that's my point
that's everyone's attitude towards
Travis etn right now that's why we want
to buy low on him so let's look at the
important things with Travis etn's
offensive environment the Jaguars are a
top seven offense in scoring and the EPA
per play Trevor Lawrence looks like he's
actually pulled you know the Jared Goff
the Peyton Manning where he's good in
year two horrific in year one gets
really good in year two we don't always
see it so far we're seeing what Trevor
Lawrence you know fair play to Christian
Kirk Jose Jones Doug Peterson everyone
that helped make this offense work and
unfortunately like if you had gone back
in August and told everyone this like
hey Lawrence is going to be great this
is going to be a top seven offense and
any efficiency metric you want to look
at
etn probably would have been going as a
second round pick instead of the third
or fourth round DK Metcalf for the
Seattle Seahawks and don't be afraid to
even wait a week on this one you know we
got a matchup coming up against the
Lions defense that did a fantastic job
shutting down Justin Jefferson last week
they took the number two Corner Jeffrey
acuda had him match up with Jefferson
every single play with help of a second
Defender that's why Adam thielen and KJ
Osborne company were able to go off on
the other side so I do think this could
be a title lock a week but in general
guys look at this Seahawks team I mean
Geno Smith this season 15th and yards
per attempt third and adjust the
completion rate seventh in QB rating
eighth in PFF passing grade the guy's
been a good quarterback maybe an average
Quarterback that's fine we thought he
was gonna be the worst quarterback in
the entire NFL The Way We Were drafting
these wide receivers before the season
started I mean DK Metcalf is someone in
Dynasty Fantasy Football was going as a
top five receiver before the rush trade
happened so the talent's never been in
question we've been worried about the
offense well to the Seahawks credit
they're moving with more Tempo they have
to pass the ball more because their
defense can't stop anyone right now and
Geno isn't terrible let's talk a little
bit about Alan Robinson another guy
where he's not going to probably meet
the expectations we had some people were
hoping that we could see the Rams have
two top 12 wide receivers potentially
clearly Cooper cup and Matthew Stafford
you know have their own ways about them
and I think we're going to continue to
see cup just mostly smashing but with
Alan Robinson I refuse to believe that
the Rams number two pass game option is
going to continue to be this disinvolved
in the offense you look at last you the
stretch run that obj had what about
Robert Woods remember this time last
year everyone freaking out about Robert
Woods what was he when he finally got
injured the ppry wide receiver 12
overall so with Alan Robinson it hasn't
been that pretty but guys if you've
watched these games he really has been
close very close to having much more go
his way Josh Jacobs with the Las Vegas
Raiders this one's interesting I know we
had to scare last week with the sickness
going on he did wind up playing though
had a great game he's looked awesome
this whole season just in terms of my
personal eye test you know having
watched every game Josh Jacobs one of
the better running backs in the league I
think this year with the football in his
hand he's third and missed tackles for
us for Kerry he's seventh in yards after
contact for Kerry he just hasn't been
getting touchdowns because the Raiders
are one of only six teams without a
rushing touchdown yet now when you look
at those six teams that haven't scored a
rushing touchdown a lot of them haven't
been scoring many touchdown pounds the
Raiders are actually the League's 10th
ranked scoring offense so it's just been
bad luck from Josh Jacobs he got to the
one yard line last week and they had a
fall start so he didn't have a chance to
jam into the end zone and Devonte Adams
scores the next play the usage has been
far better than we anticipated Justin
Jefferson Jamar Chase CD lamb Devonte
Adams any of these top wide receivers
that unfortunately been disappointing
for the better part of the past two
weeks so when we saw week one these guys
look like they would never have you know
under 150 plus yards again just you know
the complete camaraderie with them in
their new situations usually going off
and then you know CD lamb had the DAC
injury and then Devonte Adams he's been
scoring but has him again in the big
yards Justin Jefferson's getting double
teams so Mark chases hasn't been playing
his best football over the past two
weeks if you can find a panic fantasy
manager or just someone willing to trade
again one of the most elite wide
receiver fantasy Assets in the league if
he can get them to trade for let's say
you know a mid low end rb1 someone like
Austin Eckler someone like maybe Ezekiel
Elliott if someone said following out on
that that's probably not going to happen
but you know build a trade offer with
these guys don't be afraid to go get one
of these struggling wide receivers who
we still all know has the potential to
have between 150 and 200 targets